hello and welcome to drive at your car
show on DW coming up a luxurious family
sedan the new Skoda Superb welcome to
the future a self-driving truck from
Mercedes and a new pocket rocket the
mini john cooper works how about the car
tester Sasha can op sees himself as
twice lucky his job takes him to my orca
and he gets to test the nude mini john
cooper works minis aren't you small
their sporty they have been since
Minnie's first monte carlo rally victory
in 1964 and here we have the new model
that's cook one's heart emoji no on
the mini john cooper works is not to be
confused with the mini cooper s the JCW
is the most powerful mini ever made with
better handling and more driving fun
it's 170 kilowatt engine puts the rubber
to the road making the leap from 0 to
100 km/h in 6.1 seconds top speed is
electronically capped at 246 km/h
wounded Zip disk of a license Sasha
admits 170 kilowatts doesn't sound like
much and it may not be enough for
hardcore mini fans plus many had been
hoping for many with all-wheel drive but
they'll be waiting in vain the current
frame with a short wheelbase doesn't
have room for it many drivers looking to
zip up and down hills might do better
with the original most aventon of my
often woman yo mistake many famously won
its first overall victory at the monte
carlo rally in 1964 leaving its larger
competitors in the dust manyone the next
year as well in 1967 finnish rally
driver renault aaltonen brought home yet
another prestigious first from monte
carlo ziba no 60 Rana aaltonen remembers
his 67 victory as a very very tough
battle against much bigger cars back
then it was a mini 1275 cooper s but
that had been reborn to 1,300 CC s even
so he was up against two liter cars that
had more power and he beat them thanks
to the minis better handling to the
Huntley cut from mini conservative
loggin
now there's a redesigned sport
suspension and wide tires for better
Road contact but would he still rather
drive his old many from back in the day
of the faucet altona says no he'd rather
take the new mini out on the street the
John Cooper Works has a two liter engine
an enormous and flexible torque so when
he's driving in fourth gear for example
he can take sharp turns and stay in
fourth he doesn't have to keep shifting
up and down like he would on the
racetrack inst so as a my property to
bidding we often see a continually
quinones out the new john cooper works
lets the drivers sit back and enjoy the
ride the third generation many once
again shows who's boss in the sport
compact class and this one definitely
shines through the curves rano aaltonen
puts it through its paces
it's fighter second gear hey Sam and
third out of crimson and he hits the
brakes cos gave it back to second and
then he steps on the gas but the whole
time he feels like he's driving on Rails
so he'd rather take the new mini out on
the road the Big John can be recognized
by its new LED headlights and extra
large air intakes in the front apron
from stem to stem the agile Sportster
measures just under 3 meters 90 and back
there's a rear spoiler a new diffuser
and the sports exhaust systems chrome
tailpipes adding a visual element to the
engines brawny racing sport sound the
sports bucket seats sets the john cooper
works apart from its more domesticated
siblings as to the better multifunction
steering wheel the sports instrument
panel and the stainless steel pedals a
pop-up display on top of the dash is
optional but does our car tester share
rano aaltonen enthusiasm for this mighty
mini yet Connie says Sasha says he was
already impressed after a few kilometers
on the road now on the racetrack he's
convinced it's a great small nimble car
sure Porsche is faster but it has the
price tag to match and as far back as
1962 the mini proved that a small car
can win big meanie avisan zeph's and I'm
client Otto come on and give it
I way to pharmadene north car Chester
yen Stratman is taking the new Skoda
Superb for a spin the first generation
debuted in 2001 a second in 2008 and now
comes the third does it live up to its
name the superb is the check car makers
top of the range model with more than
700,000 units sold to date it's holding
its own on the international market more
than 15,000 suburbs have been registered
in Germany annually since 2012 now Scott
is hoping to add another chapter to its
success story Josh McCown sophistical
imelda lobby of skoda explains that the
superb is scotus flagship it brings
together everything the brand stands for
such as space and unique emotional
design skoda aims to accentuate that
even more with this new model scotus
marketing is dignified and restrained
they highlight the suburbs clear lines
characteristic elegance perfect
proportions and bi-xenon headlights
the Lauren and Clement edition honors
school is 120 year history with
confidence and pride the company's
founders both named wat Slav established
the principle only the best is good
enough for our customers the 9th cortado
pienses the new Skoda Superb has all
sorts of options including a range of
assistance systems one you must have is
the dynamic chassis control an adaptive
suspension that can be set to standard
sport or comfort there's also an eco an
individual driving mode
the traffic jam assist is a combination
of lane departure warning and distance
control systems even it speeds less than
65 km/h the superb can keep to its lame
and brake automatically if the car ahead
slows down and it can't accelerate when
traffic allows that but the driver has
to have both hands on the steering wheel
as long as the car is moving the suburbs
interior has the same quality
workmanship as its VW cousins
just like the skoda fabia the superb can
present smartphone content on its
infotainment display whether from an
Android or Apple iOS
yeah that's done for more yen says the
new suburbs wheelbase is 8 centimeters
longer it's also 5 centimeters wider
that makes for a spacious interior and
good legroom you could almost danced a
tango back here income from the school
disapproves trunk can be kicked open you
got your hands full you can open the
tailgate with a tap of the toe there's
625 liters inside expandable by pulling
levers to the left and right which gives
you seven hundred and 60 liters but you
have to pull the head rest up a bit to
flatten the bed lettings d cops tosin at
first all seen da manhã no flaw a lot of
licking and so to sum up it's a luxury
sedan and cargo hauler Jen says only a
Skoda Superb station wagon can top it
but car buyers who can't wait for skoda
to roll out a station wagon will be
happy with the sedan and Germany it
starts at a bit under 25 thousand euros
if you're someone who enjoys per the
moment camping trips the cadi beach
might be just right Volkswagen made
lifestyle of factor in the design of the
Caddy trampers successor in Germany it
starts at thirty thousand euros with the
all-wheel drive option the rear can be
turned into a bed or even accommodate a
tent meanwhile Audi has presented its TT
clubsport turbo concept car and it's a
brute it's 2.5 liter TFSI engine
delivers 441 kilowatts of power the
innovation is an electrically powered
compressor supporting the conventional
turbocharger at busse sprinting ability
and peak power the special by turbo
technology is almost ready for
production in the diesel engine variant
a giant of a vehicle is getting new
license plates it's going to be taking
to the highway in the US state of Nevada
it's the only place where it's allowed
to move freely and this is the big rig
that's going to be wearing the plates a
freightliner inspiration truck outfitted
with a highway pilot autonomous driving
system developed by mercedes and against
all the ones on the mountain styling of
Daimler says this truck complements the
mercedes-benz future truck 2025 which
they presented last year in Germany it's
a milestone for us freightliner rigs the
first time ever that a heavy-duty
self-driving truck has been granted a
license for public road use this truck
is one of two autonomous trucks that
have been licensed for public roads and
regular traffic in Nevada it's still a
prototype eventually Mercedes plans to
put driverless long-haul rigs into
series production the first test took
place last year on a cordon off section
of a German Autobahn afterwards Mercedes
continued testing the highway pilot
clocking up 16,000 kilometers per
vehicle on a test circuit and
configuring it for use on US highways
the Friedlander inspiration truck is
based on the u.s. freightliner cascadia
evolution model with the addition of the
highway pilot system
descenso like mutton zeilinger says the
sensor includes a stereo camera which
monitors the highways lane lines and
keeps the truck in the lane the radar
sensors at the front of the truck
regulate the distance to the vehicle
ahead of it and there are interfaces to
the power train brakes and steering
which is used for lateral guidance this
fall 60 miss out on all my violence
American cameras offer the driver a view
around the entire vehicle when the
driver activates the highway pilot the
truck takes over the steering currently
that's allowed up to speeds of 60 miles
an hour the highway pilot lets the
driver know when they need to step in
for example when there's a construction
site or when the truck leaves the
highway in the meantime the driver can
do other things like take orders or
coordinate connections Anton Zeilinger
says the driver is the core component of
the system they're not going to
eliminate the driver they're looking for
optimal ways to assist and support the
driver autonomous driving systems will
help the drivers stay fit and alert so
it's an important part of driver safety
and of economical operations it could
all be some farm leading the Freelanders
interior is light and friendly in its
design during the hall the driver stays
in the driver's seat but the rig also
has an area for the driver to relax
during breaks
I'm intestines Martin says the company
carried out tests on their own test
circuit they determined that when
truckers work on something else
autonomous driving helps reduce driver
fatigue by about twenty-five percent
what's end up getting 12 according to
that's an added safety bonus for
everyone on the road the highway pilot
steers the rig and keeps it within the
lane lines it also has a collision
prevention function which maintains the
set speed or adjusts it through breaking
but it doesn't initiate lane changes or
pass other vehicles the technology will
be ready for series production in about
10 years so which will be ready first
self-driving trucks or self-driving cars
it's all be dust before view Wolfgang
ban out of Daimler says we'll see self
driving trucks on long stretches of
highway first before driverless cars in
the city highway traffic patterns on the
highway are much less complex and trucks
are on the road for long hours each day
so the technology is more urgent and
useful there that gives the trucking
industry and edge but the regulatory
framework isn't there yet road traffic
regulations need to be adapted and that
raises a lot of questions one issue is
what conditions manufacturers need to
meet to get a system licensed and street
legal but discussions are underway with
the regulatory authorities and he's
confident these issues will all be
addressed in the next few years pisgah
soon we can haggle aviane between mitten
be helping becca injustice in xtrm to
vascular system
in deutschland Alexis a our tipster
Emmanuel Schaefer says lexus is a niche
player in Germany but in the US the
brand outsells Volkswagen and rivals BMW
and Mercedes Lexus models are built in
Japan but they're tested at Germany's
Nurburgring racetrack lexus is Toyota's
luxury vehicle division its name is an
acronym for luxury export to the US but
the brand is now marketed around the
globe the first Lexus to be sold in
Germany was the LS 400 back in nineteen
ninety the sedan was the beginning of a
success story that continues to this day
then whoosh what lakpha manual says
alexis was founded in the u.s. in 1983
when Toyota designers rented a home in
California to get a sense for
well-heeled Americans the ls400 made its
US market debut in 1989 and came out in
Germany the next year the fourth
generation of the car was called the ls
600h the world's first full hybrid sedan
and hit the streets in 2007 right from
the start Lexus was synonymous with
luxury fully loaded the first ls400
boasted features not common in its day
like the first series production sat-nav
automatic climate control a stereo
system driver side airbag traction
control and cruise control
these are a les fue una mano says this
ls400 has over a million kilometers on
the clock and still has its original
engine and transmission there's even
seatbelt pretensioners and a heated rear
bench a man well can't resist taking the
ls400 out for a spin thereby putting a
few more kilometers on the odometer of
this million kilometer car over the
years Lexus has been showered with
awards for its bold combination of
thrifty engines and lavish features this
recognition motivated the car maker to
expand into other vehicle segments
so I told Manuel says Lexus debuted the
first lifestyle station wagon the is
bored cross in 2001 and 2005 it had the
first luxury SUV with a hybrid drive
this is the 2009 model and this is the
current one Lexus was the first and is
still the only automaker to offer buyers
a complete full hybrid range of luxury
cars the Japanese brand even boasts a
supercar the limited edition LFA with
its 412 kilowatt v10 engine and carbon
fiber body the LFA finished first in its
class in the Nurburgring 24 hour race
three years ago alenka manual says the
NX radiator grill isn't for everyone and
the alternating convex and concave shape
is tough to produce some said it was too
pricey for series production but lexus
did it will excellence at schoo shaft
was he doesn't give miss all the RCF
also sports the lexus diabolo radiator
grille developed in 2014 the car is a
further development of the RC sports
coupe a the F stands for the Fuji
International Speedway where Lexus
tested the car's performance the high
performance sport versions of the RC are
also F models
European competitors are now following
the Japanese brands lead and making the
kind of hybrid engine that have become a
Lexus trademark
the Lamborghini 350gt
back in 1964 the first sports car
branded with the bull logo came onto the
market its mission to run rings around
Ferraris horse
a good long smooth our classy car expert
Cousteau Bauer says the legend
surrounding the birth of the Lamborghini
350 GT is one of the most famous
anecdotes in automotive history
ferruccio lamborghini owned a profitable
tractor factory and a ferrari 250 GT but
he wasn't really happy with the car and
told Enzo Ferrari why right to his face
Ferrari retorted that Lamborghini should
stick to making tractors Lamborghini was
so angry that he founded his own company
automobile II Lamborghini and introduced
his own supercard the 350 GT the new
company was based in sant'agata
bolognese and italy's emilia-romagna
region barely 20 kilometers away from
Ferraris headquarters at Maranello and
that's where the ambitious Ferruccio
Lamborghini poached his top managers
from dr. kristov says there's a world of
distance between tractors and super cars
but ferruccio lamborghini was very lucky
that at the time Ferraris development
department was in a dispute with their
boss so Lamborghini was able to hire
away three of Ferraris best technicians
they developed the 350 GT and left
Ferrari eating their dust the media sang
the 350 GT praises calling it the best
most refined supercar ever a real slap
in the face for Enzo Ferrari in 1964
just two years after the founding of
automobile Lamborghini the 350 GT made
its debut at the geneva motor show
que Bella machi que Bella machina
Christophe gushes he's blinded by his
beauty the instruments the leather
upholstery everything's of the finest
quality but it's the cars profile that
impresses him most it's elongated front
and the filigree roof he tells us it is
built using the legendary Superleggera
construction method which employs a
lightweight aluminum body and a space
frame to ensure stability the perfect
ingredients for a supercar in spite of
the powerful 12-cylinder engine under
the hood the Lamborghini weighs in at
under twelve hundred kilos less than a
current model VW golf inside the
Lamborghini more is more there are more
instruments more switches more displays
yet the result is still economic drivers
enjoy all the comforts without
sacrificing performance
the quiet 12-cylinder engine is a real
feast for the eyes and was
state-of-the-art at the time Ferruccio
Lamborghini owned almost every supercar
produced in the 1950s and 60s but he
felt these domesticated race cars lacked
creature comforts and their engines
didn't run smoothly enough he was
determined that the first Lamborghini
would change all that Christophe says
the 350 GT is easy to handle and has a
very broad power band when taking curves
fast he says it first shift slightly
over the front wheels and then gently
swings out at the back well the Ferraris
of the time still used rigid axles the
Lamborghini had independent suspension
and coil springs on every wheel
Jurgensen it's a lot of hingham 10 feet
on a yacht
but so much high-tech have its price
back in 1967 the 350 GT sold for the
equivalent of thirty thousand euros
enough to buy three porsche 911 tease
but then 12 cylinders never come cheap
other than the v12 engines the Miura
conte and other later model Lamborghinis
didn't have much in common with the 350
GT it was the one Lamborghini that
managed to be both a devilishly fast
super car and an elegant Gran Turismo
that's all christo says the 350gt isn't
as flashy as Lamborghinis later more
spectacular models and it wasn't a big
seller either just 141 of them changed
hands between 1964 and 1967 still the
350 GT established Lamborghini as super
car maker and was unrivaled in its time
today at 350 GT in good condition will
set you back at least two hundred twenty
thousand euros around the same price
you'd pay for a Ferrari from the same
error next time on drive it sporty
performance meets timeless elegance the
new Porsche gt3 RS and a look at the sea
at me which runs on natural gas
you
you